Prof: Okay. Good morning.
You are the last people left
standing.
Right?
I can tell you at the beginning
of this semester which of these
lectures will have the lowest
attendance rate.
And it's this one.
And I'll tell you where it's
going to peak again--as we get
closer to the final exam.
But you are the good folks.
You're here.
You're sticking with it,
so good for you.
If you can make it to section
tonight and tomorrow,
that's great too.
What are we doing today?
Well, last time we left off
talking about opera in the
nineteenth century.
And the session before that,
we were talking about the
development of the piano in the
nineteenth century.
Today, what do we want to do?
We're going to talk about the
development of the symphony,
specifically the symphony
orchestra,
in the course of the nineteenth
century--
and it did undergo significant
changes,
as we will see.
What symphonies have we visited
here in our course?
Who can give me the name of a
symphony that we've studied?
Roger.
Student:
>
Prof: Beethoven's Fifth
Symphony.
We did a lot with that at the
very beginning of the class.
Any other symphony?
Elizabeth.
Student: Beethoven's
Sixth.
Prof: Beethoven's Sixth,
which was the basis of the
Saybrook concert.
Any other symphonies?
Angela.
Student: Beethoven's
Ninth.
Prof: Beethoven's Ninth.
Yes, we talked about that in an
early lecture.
>
So we've done a lot of
Beethoven.
We haven't--and Thaddeus.
Student: The
"Surprise Symphony."
Prof: The "Surprise
Symphony."
Good.
The "Surprise
Symphony"
of Joseph Haydn.
So we've done some Haydn.
Anything else?
We haven't mentioned somebody I
thought you might mention.
>
Student: Mozart.
Prof: Mozart.
Okay.
Mozart's G Minor Symphony.
So we've done Mozart,
Haydn, and Beethoven for the
most part,
but there's a lot of symphonic
composition after these
individuals,
extends into the early
twentieth century and that's
what we're going to track today.
So today's lecture will
generally be about the symphony
from one M to the other M.
You hear about the three B's in
music.
Well, these are the two M's,
from Mozart to Gustav Mahler.
Let's start with Mozart.
Let's play just a little bit of
his "Eine kleine
Nachtmusik,"
"A Little Night
Music."
It's a sort of divertimento,
evening music for
entertainment.
Let's listen to a little bit
about it and then I'll say
something.
>
What can we say about that
music?
Well, we've talked a lot about
this before.
It's very patterned.
It's very symmetrical.
It's balanced.
We have antecedent and
consequent phrases and they come
in the music with the classical
period.
What about the orchestra?
Well, it's rather small in that
it's dominated principally by
the strings.
And we had a couple of
Listening Exercises where we'd
see the strings play the themes
and then the woodwinds maybe
come back to echo them or to
answer them.
But most of the musical
material is getting presented by
the strings.
The texture--well,
the texture is rather thin here
because it's not a very big
orchestra, a thin texture.
And what can we say also about
the texture?
Well, it tends to be rather
polyphonic, homophonic or
monophonic?
Well, in that case, homophonic.
Basically, you got a melody
plus accompaniment.
And we could also
say--something that we've talked
about--that this music has a
kind of rhetorical strategy to
it.
We have this idea of music.
It sounds like a melody,
it sounds like a theme,
or music that sounds like it's
coming between themes,
of leading us somewhere,
transitional music,
music that may be a contrasting
theme,
music that ends a section.
So it's music that does
something, music that's trying
to get us from point A to point
B and point C and so on,
so it's a sort of rhetorical
music,
teleological music if you will.
Okay.
Now, let's turn to a piece of
romantic music.
And before we do that I'm going
to say a thing or two about this
romantic music.
It's a piece by Tchaikovsky
from his Romeo and
Juliet,
and I think we have the titles
of the pieces that we'll be
listening to on the board up
there today--
so from his Romeo and
Juliet.
And you've probably heard this
music before because it used to
be--a lot of it used to be used
in cartoon music.
Anytime there was a love scene
this particular music would come
on.
So what are its qualities here?
Well, first of all,
it has a long,
sweeping melody here in
romantic music,
a long, sweeping melody that is
rather asymmetrical in shape.
Instead of having neat units of
two plus two plus two,
it could go on over bars or
maybe it'll be a seven-bar
phrase, something like that.
So the melodies tend to be long;
they tend to be asymmetrical.
Rhythm--think about rhythm in
the music that we've been
listening to.
My paradigm here is the
beginning of the Brandenburg
Fifth Concerto Grosso,
in which the rhythm starts out
>.
It's very regular.
It's like a machine gun,
almost, or a sewing machine,
or some kind of repetitive
process there.
When we get into the classical
period, rhythm is somewhat more
relaxed but it is still a
pattern, >
but here, with this music in
the romantic period,
the themes are not only long
and asymmetrical;
the rhythms don't seem to shake
out in patterns that allow us to
tap our feet or allow us to
conduct it easily.
So we have ties over bars.
We have lots of syncopation.
We have irregular phrasing,
somewhat irregular metrical
patterns as well.
Tempo--we've talked a little
bit about this before and this
idea of tempo rubato
here.
In romantic music,
we get wild swings of tempo in
that it can be coming along at a
regular pace and then slow way,
way down and then speed up to
get back on track and slow down
and so on.
And this is part and parcel of
the romantic aesthetic in the
sense that it tends to swing
wildly from one extreme to
another,
wildly in terms of rhythm and
wildly in terms of dynamics.
We can go from very,
very quiet to very,
very loud in a way that Mozart
couldn't.
Remember we were talking about
Mozart's piano,
which weighed about one tenth
of what this piano weighs up
here.
This piano probably weighs
about eight hundred pounds.
Mozart's probably weighed about
one hundred pounds.
So this is a much bigger
instrument.
You can play very quietly on it
or you can make a huge sound on
it;
same thing with the orchestra
and we'll come back to that
point today.
Mozart had a modest orchestra.
Mahler at the end of this
period had a huge orchestra.
So this allows for these wild
swings.
The romantic period is sort of
a bipolar period,
I guess, in terms of music in
that regard.
Okay.
Having said that,
let's listen to what we might
call a prototypical moment in
romantic music out of
Tchaikovsky's overture to
Romeo and Juliet.
>
Now it starts to build,
a little bit of melodic
sequence working up here,
>
reaching higher and higher each
time.
>
So it's a really remarkable
passage.
It's made possible by this
newly enlarged orchestra so
let's talk about this orchestra
for a moment,
and we're going to reference
here our four "food
types" or our four
instrumental groups for the--
for classical art music,
starting with the strings.
We don't really have any new
instruments here in the romantic
period.
We still have basically the
four string instruments of
violin, viola,
cello and double bass,
but they are different.
They're different from the
instrument that Mozart was
playing.
What happened?
Well, in the nineteenth century
the construction of the violin
was changed rather
significantly,
and I think I could just hold
my hand out here,
maybe demonstrate this kind of
thing.
First of all,
there was a higher bridge put
on it.
If you have the bridge holding
up the strings in an
eighteenth-century violin it
might be like that--
a nineteenth-century violin
like that,
higher bridge.
That allows you to have more
tension.
It puts more tension on the
entire instrument and at the
same time,
the strings that had been used,
which were made of--
anybody have a sense of what
violin strings in the eighteenth
century were made of?
Chelsea.
Student: Catgut.
Prof: Catgut sometimes,
yes.
Yes, animal lovers, catgut.
More normally sheep gut. Okay?
So sheep gut,
and that wouldn't--the tension
that could be put on that was
not as great as if you were
using a wire string.
So in the nineteenth century,
technological advances,
wire strings,
more tension,
higher bridge,
and to--well,
also the fingerboard was
extended.
It's longer so oftentimes with
a Stradivarius they'd chop off
the fingerboard and put
another--
a new fingerboard on it and put
it all back together again.
What else?
I know I'm missing one other
important thing.
Well, maybe that will have to
do it for the moment,
and what we'll end up with--oh,
I know.
The bow.
If you look at an
eighteenth-century bow and go to
our collection of historical
musical instruments on Hillhouse
Avenue,
the amount of horsehair there
is rather narrow.
It's almost double when you get
to the nineteenth-century bow.
So the bow is bigger.
So the whole thing is more
powerful,
and I've asked Jacob just to
bring in his viola,
which is fundamentally a
nineteenth-century viola in
construction,
and just rip through a couple
of things,
just to give you a sense of the
volume of the instrument.
Play anything.
>
Okay.
So that's all I wanted him to
do but just to give you a
sense--that's a big,
rich sound.
Play a couple of--can you play
a couple of chords like maybe
the ending of something with
double- and triple-stops--with
much volume?
>
Okay.
So big, powerful
nineteenth-century violin as
opposed to the smaller one that
Mozart had.
Let's talk about the woodwinds.
Here in this family,
new instruments were
introduced.
First of all,
we have the piccolo up at the
top.
We've heard the piccolo before.
Remember in the storm scene of
the "Pastoral
Symphony,"
number six, the Beethoven storm
scene.
If you wanted to get a sense of
the whistling wind up there,
that's what he did.
He had the piccolo play way,
way up high.
Then you could hear it.
It just kind of gave that
effect.
At the other end there of the
extreme we have the double--
the contra--or double bassoon
being added,
the low bassoon playing down an
octave lower than--
is that correct,
Lynda, playing down an octave
or even lower than that?
Lynda: Oh,
maybe about that.
It's enormous.
Prof: It's enormous,
and actually I think the
bassoon--the contrabassoon plays
lower than any instrument in the
orchestra--
is that correct--in terms of
actual frequency.
So it's adding to both the high
and the low range of the
woodwind family,
and a new instrument was
introduced.
Actually, it had been around in
certain quarters,
a new instrument called the
English horn,
and I think we have that up
there on our list of terms.
Is the English horn from
England and is it a horn?
No.
It's actually from France and
Germany and it's a woodwind
instrument.
It's not a brass instrument at
all.
It's kind of a low or tenor
oboe.
So it's a kind of oboe in a
tenor range but it has a
beautiful, rich quality to it,
a somewhat nostalgic quality.
Arguably, the most famous
English horn passage is the one
that you're about to hear,
which comes from the slow
movement of Dvorak's "New
World Symphony"
which,
as you might suspect,
was written here in the United
States,
actually, in Spillville,
Iowa--in New York City and in
Spillville, Iowa.
So here's a little bit of the
English horn solo out of the
"New World Symphony."
>
It's lovely, lovely, lovely.
It's funny about music,
what it can do for you.
My mother's family was actually
from Iowa, a farm family from
Iowa, and as a child they took
me to Spillville,
Iowa.
"Get in the car;
we're going to get culture this
afternoon.
No more softball games.
We're going for culture."
So I went to Spillville,
and I can't hear that music
without thinking of that
particular family or those
particular people in Iowa.
It's weird.
It's kind of--as we've said
before, music provides an entry
to the inner recesses of your
memory sometimes.
In any event,
aside from that discursus,
let us continue now with the
brass family.
We--what were the two
instruments in the orchestra
that we have encountered up to
this point in terms of brass
instruments?
What have we heard in a
symphony?
Elizabeth.
Student: The trumpet and
the trombone.
Prof: The trumpet and
Okay, fair enough,
trumpet and trombone.
There's one other important one
that actually was in the
orchestra before the trombone.
Chris.
Student: The French horn.
Prof: The French horn,
and in point in fact the
trumpet and French horn were in
there first.
Then Beethoven,
with the Fifth Symphony brings
in the trombone,
but it's not until the
nineteenth century that the
trombone gets added to the
orchestra.
Where does Beethoven do so?
Well, he does it in the finale
of his Fifth Symphony when he
wants this particularly powerful
brass sound so let's listen to
the opening of the finale of the
Fifth Symphony where the
trombones are brought into the
orchestra for the first time for
this particular effect.
>
Okay. Here we go.
So that's how Beethoven gets
his kind of heroic effect.
He's doing three things there
in the finale:
One, switching from minor
>
to >
major.
He has--it's a very triadic
theme and he's bringing in the
heavy artillery,
the newly invented heavy
artillery--
or at least newly introduced
heavy artillery--
the trombone there.
And it gives it this powerful,
if you will,
in the vernacular,
sort of "ballsy"
effect with that brass.
And this got extended to the
low brass as well.
The one family of the brasses
that we've talked about that we
haven't really explained in
terms of the history of the
orchestra is the tuba here.
When does the tuba get
introduced?
Well, it gets introduced right
about this time,
about eighteen twenty-five,
eighteen thirty or so.
The first composer to use the
tuba in an orchestral piece was
Hector Berlioz in the
Symphonie Fantastique
that we're going to be embracing
in sections this week.
So we have the tuba coming in
here, and actually it was,
as you can see there,
originally an instrument called
the ophicleide.
It was a French instrument and
Berlioz heard this as a kind of
giant keyed bugle in the
military bands of the period.
Think of the French Revolution.
Think of the Napoleonic wars,
all of these troops marching up
and down with the brass bands
along the
Champs-Elysées.
He hears this.
He brings this military
instrument in to the symphonic
orchestra to add depth to the
lower part of the brasses.
Let's go back to our Dvorak
piece here,
the Dvorak "New World
Symphony,"
second movement,
and here we can hear the power
and the depth of the newly
enlarged brass section,
>
way down there,
that low note played by the
tuba and so on.
So that's something of the
brass group as an ensemble.
Let's think of these
instruments individually.
If we look back at a symphony
by Mozart, not only is the
orchestra stronger,
but how he is using these brass
instruments is very different.
We looked at the French horn
before, and we're now going to
focus on the French horn.
In the very beginning of our
course,
we had a professional French
hornist in here,
Eva Heater, and she
played--does anybody remember
anything of interest about the
instrument that she played and
how it differed from the modern
French horn?
What didn't that instrument
have that the modern French horn
has?
Roger.
Student:
>
Prof: Keys.
Okay.
Keys or valves,
yeah.
That's it exactly:
keys or valves.
That gets put on the instrument.
Instead of sliding in these
crooks and changing the length
of the pipe that way,
they figured a way of having
valves and you could do it
quickly and--
with keys, but that's a
nineteenth-century invention.
An eighteenth-century horn just
over-blew and it could play some
things such as
>
very easily,
repeated pitches,
>.
Remember our horn concerto of
Mozart or >.
It could over-blow up the
harmonic frequencies,
up the partials as we said
before, with ease,
but it couldn't play chromatic
kinds of things and as a result
it's kind of stuck there in the
background kind of providing
what I like to think of as a
sonic glue for the orchestra,
but it rarely plays any solos
in the orchestral fabric outside
of a concerto.
Well, let's see what happens to
the French horn inside of the
orchestra here in the nineteenth
century,
where it begins to come forth
as a solo instrument because the
melody it can play is so much
more complex and much more
interesting.
So here's a famous French horn
lick out of Brahms's First
Symphony, <<music
playing>>
and back to the horns
>.
Listen to the depth.
It's a lovely passage but it's
featuring the brasses and
particularly the solo French
horn.
I guess the thing also to
notice here is how slow the
music is going--slowly the music
is going.
It's all slowed down,
kind of going at a crawl here.
And that's an interesting point
about the whole
nineteenth-century notion of
time and what they thought about
time and the passage of time--
the early nineteenth century,
the beginning of the discovery
of the whole discipline of
paleontology and how old the
earth was and how many years
civilization had existed and so
on.
And it is all getting extended.
Instead of biblically,
five to seven thousand years,
now it's twenty-five million
years,
which of course has been
greatly extended since then,
but everything here is being
allowed to slow down.
And by way of reference,
let's go back to our Mozart
here and think about how he
constructed it.
>
Well, there we have,
again, the beginning of
"Eine kleine
Nachtmusik"
and he has a chordal pattern,
triadic, going up.
That pattern lasts about four
seconds, if you
>
two, three, four,
come down, one,
two, three, four--four seconds
on each chord.
He's moving through his
material rather quickly and
we'll say why in a moment.
Now, by way of contrast,
let's go to music,
oh, sixty or so
later--years--or so later in the
middle of the nineteenth century
and focus on an overture by
Wagner here,
overture to The Flying
Dutchman,
and we're going to listen to
just the end of this and sort of
think about how long Wagner can
sit on each chord.
Mozart thought he could sit on
each chord here for about four
seconds.
How long does Wagner sit on a
chord?
>
All one chord,
change, another chord,
>
all one chord,
just triadic notes of that one
chord, changes that to minor,
just drops the third down,
same chord, <<music
playing>>
and now back to the original
chord, holding that one chord
>.
Where are we on the counter
there?
Lynda: Nine fifty-two.
Prof: Nine fifty-two,
so we had fifty-two seconds of
music there and we went through
three chords so we're averaging
about eighteen seconds per
chord,
something like that,
four or five times more than
Mozart was doing.
How can Wagner do that?
What's the difference?
Why did Mozart have to move
through his chords faster?
What's happening in this music?
Supposing you tried to play
that Wagner music with Mozart's
orchestra.
It wouldn't work.
Mozart had this dinky,
little orchestra.
How many people were in
Mozart's orchestra?
Well, depends on where he was
at a given time.
Haydn's first orchestra had
sixteen people in it.
Mozart, when he gave a concert
in Vienna usually wanted about
thirty to thirty-three.
We get to Beethoven,
we're up to fifty to sixty in a
typical Beethovenian orchestra
in Vienna eighteen ten or so.
As we move in to the later part
of the century,
these orchestras keep adding
more and more instruments,
more and more players.
You got to--well,
if we get--have all this brass
we got to balance them with more
string players so we're getting
up to eighty,
ninety, one hundred by the end
of the nineteenth century so
this is an important point.
Mozart had a very small
orchestra and as a result--or
maybe he could get away with
what he had because he had great
musical ideas.
Right.
He had to have great musical
ideas because the sound itself
wasn't going to rescue him.
With Wagner and these later
composers, they may not always
have to have the greatest of
musical ideas.
The triad is not a particularly
novel musical idea,
but he can get away with just
taking <<plays
piano>>
--he can get away with doing
that and it sounds great.
Everybody--didn't you like that
Wagner?
Didn't that sound terrific?
And it's just because he's got
this huge orchestra.
Sound, per se,
is replacing musical idea.
Mozart, terrific ideas;
Wagner, terrific orchestra,
and he knew how to use it.
So a bigger orchestra allows
longer movements.
I have said before I think that
it's axiomatic in music that the
more people you have on a stage
or involved in a performance,
the longer that performance is
going to take.
And with regard to the
symphony, how long does a
movement within a Mozart
symphony take?
If you were to look at the CDs
up here of a Mozart symphony,
what would you guess?
First movement of Mozart's G
Minor Symphony:
how long does that go?
Hm?
Student: Seven.
Prof: Yeah.
Who said that?
I can't--okay.
Oscar says seven minutes,
yeah, and actually that's about
right for the G Minor Symphony.
It's one of the shorter ones of
Mozart but let's say five to ten
minutes, ten minutes outside.
If we get to Beethoven,
how long will a movement of
Beethoven take?
Well, about twenty minutes
sometimes with his bigger
symphonies like three,
five and nine.
When we get to Mahler and
Bruckner,
the length of the movements can
go on even more,
and an entire symphony of
Mahler might go on for an hour
and a half,
so these are bigger.
The big orchestra has led to
longer symphonies and the sound
obviously is very luxuriant,
very opulent.
The sound in music probably
never gets any more opulent than
it does here at the end of the
nineteenth century.
Two other aspects involved here
having to do with the physical
world and, in a way,
technology.
Of course, the nineteenth
century is the period of the
Industrial Revolution,
and some of these innovations,
in terms of metallurgy and
design,
got applied to musical
instruments.
For example,
how many have ever played the
flute in here?
Okay, a number of people--both
male and female--
and if you look--remember the
video we saw of a Baroque flute
it actually had a very
rudimentary key pad on it,
and you look at a modern flute
and it's got this keyed system
with all these things up there,
all of the different keys and
extenders,
and that's all an invention of
the nineteenth century.
They completely reconfigured
the flute and how you play it in
the nineteenth century.
And we've talked about all
these other instruments that got
added.
So a kind of technological
revolution was applied to
musical instruments too,
but the most interesting thing
is, when you got all these
instruments together,
how much sound they could make.
Let's say you were in the--you
lived in the nineteenth century
and you wanted to hear the
biggest sound that could be
made.
What do you think you would do?
Where would you hear the
loudest sound?
Jennifer.
Student: Organ?
Prof: An organ.
Okay.
That's good.
That's pretty good,
though it wouldn't have sounded
as loud then as it does now
because now we're using
something else I'll get to,
but that's a good start.
Okay? Anything else?
It doesn't have to be musical.
What would give the biggest
sound?
Sarah.
Student:
>
Prof: I beg your pardon.
Acoustics in music halls.
Yeah, we're going to come to
that, but just in the real
world.
You're in the city of London.
What's going to annoy you the
most, make the biggest sound?
Roger.
Student:
>
Prof: A big--possibly a
bell.
Yeah, but that's back--we've
had those since the Middle Ages.
I was thinking of two things:
cannons, okay,
huge fire power there,
huge, loud sound,
deafening roar;
and one other thing that came
in in the nineteenth century:
steam engines and all the
things that it could produce--
trains, steam whistles,
this kind of thing.
But the third thing really is
this orchestra when all of these
new instruments are coming
together in such large numbers.
And once you have them all
together you got to have a place
to put them so they started
building new concert halls and
concert halls are particularly
good acoustically.
The model for this,
and I don't know if I put
this--yes, we did.
Okay.
It's up there on the board.
It's in Vienna.
It's called the
Musikverein and it's a
famous hall and it's a
remarkable hall,
maybe the most perfect musical
hall ever built.
That was the prototype,
and then other concert hall
builders around the world began
to adopt it.
We adopted it here in the
United States.
Can anybody think of a concert
hall in the United States that
is particularly famous and
acoustically beautiful outside
of Carnegie Hall that I'll talk
about in a moment?
What other one?
There's one other one,
early concert hall in the
United States.
Symphony Hall in Boston.
If you're ever in
Boston--anybody from
Massachusetts here?
Anybody been to Symphony Hall?
Okay. Go in there.
It's a knockoff of the
Musikverein so if you
want to see what Vienna looks
like go to Symphony Hall in
Boston.
There is another one that is
very close to us here that's
pretty close to the--this design
and where is that?
Built about the same time.
Our own Woolsey Hall,
a big hall seating about
twenty-five hundred people.
If you're ever in Woolsey,
notice the fundamentally
rectangular design on it.
Go in and look at the floor.
It has a suspended floor there.
And it has a suspended floor
for a particular reason.
That floor serves as a
resonator and there are other
resonators around that we
needn't go into,
but next time you're in Woolsey
go in and bounce because that's
in--
on that floor.
It's designed to have the sound
resonate more.
Now, what's the problem with
Woolsey?
Why don't string quartets like
playing in Woolsey?
Hm?
Student:
>
Prof: It's too booming.
Okay. It's too resonant.
But what was the model?
What the model is--you
get--Roger.
Student:
>
Prof: Well,
it was partly built for the
organ.
Yes, it was built for the organ
but Woolsey Hall can sound
absolutely marvelous for a
symphony orchestra--
not booming and not overly
resonant,
if what happens?
Robert.
Student:
>
Prof: If it's full of
people, because people absorb
sound.
So all of the boomingness,
the long reverberation cycle,
gets sucked out of it into our
bodies--
as sound absorbers--and it
produces this absolutely
spectacular symphonic sound so
that was the model and that's
the--
and I was struck the other day
when I went to Nashville.
They've done a knockoff of the
Musikverein in Nashville
in that Schermerhorn Symphony
Hall down there too.
It's brazen but just take that
design from Vienna and put it
right there in the middle of
Nashville--pretty interesting.
Okay.
So that's another thing we have
to kind of keep track of.
Carnegie Hall is a little bit
different in terms of its
design.
All right.
Now let's take a look at what I
call the main line here of
symphonic composers--
and it's mostly a German
tradition,
right, a German symphonic
tradition.
But that became the model for
the United States,
and that's why they brought
Dvorak here;
Tchaikovsky came to the United
States and was involved in the
opening of Carnegie Hall in New
York City in eighteen
ninety-three--
as you can see,
running from Mozart down to
Gustav Mahler.
Not all of them were German.
Who up there is not German?
Roger.
Student: Tchaikovsky.
Prof: Tchaikovsky was
from where?
Student: Russia.
Prof: Russia.
Who else is not German?
Oscar.
Student:
>
Prof: I beg your pardon.
Student: Berlioz.
Prof: Berlioz?
Yes.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Of course, Berlioz.
He is, of course,
French and we'll talk about him
in section tonight.
Anybody else?
Well, Dvorak. He's Czech.
Okay.
So--but they are all in this
fundamentally German-educated
tradition extending really from
Bach in--
but he didn't write
symphonies--into Mozart,
Haydn, Beethoven down to Mahler.
So we're going to go to the end
of the line now and talk a
little bit about Gustav Mahler.
Any of you listened to--ever
heard a symphony of Mahler?
If you've heard any music of
Mahler, raise your hand.
Okay.
I would say about a third of
our class has.
Let's talk about that just for
a moment.
I would say that if you haven't
been introduced to Mahler,
don't miss this one.
It's really great stuff and I
hope to be able to convince you
of that here today if you're
kind enough to come along with
us here in this trip along the
road of high art music--
and we don't want to miss the
pinnacle,
in a way, of high art music.
For me these two M's are very
important, Mozart and Mahler.
They write some really
astonishing music,
in different kinds of ways.
So Gustav Mahler--who was he?
Well, he was a Jew born in
Moravia,
which is a section of
Czechoslovakia,
got his musical education in
Vienna,
was a pianist and principally a
conductor.
He earned his living conducting.
And he went all around the
world conducting,
and we'll talk more about that
next time--where he conducted.
And he composed mostly in the
summertime.
He would go out to the Alps in
one of these mountain retreats
in--where he could have solitude
and he would compose.
And in the course of time,
he wrote principally nine
symphonies and something we're
going to talk about next time,
which is the orchestral song.
But we're focusing on just one
symphony today--indeed his first
symphony, 1888.
It starts in an unusual way
with a kind of homage to
Beethoven because the beginning
of this--
Mahler's first symphony--sounds
like the beginning of
Beethoven's Ninth Symphony,
but let's just listen to a bit
of it.
Oftentimes with Mahler people
talk about the
"cosmic"
quality of Mahler's music.
Well, what does that mean?
What kind of sound is cosmic?
Well, maybe it's kind of open.
Maybe it's kind of hollow.
Maybe it seems to be endlessly
spacey in that way,
so here's a good example of
Mahler's style,
particularly his cosmic style.
>
And those trumpets are sort of
off-stage trumpets,
perhaps giving you more a sense
of far-out distance.
So that's the beginning of the
first movement,
and I've put this diagram up
here because it's interesting
that so much of the material
that he is working with derives
from a particular complex,
a particular cell of material.
Mahler is a developer and
that's, generally speaking,
what this German main line
tradition is into--not always.
Tchaikovsky's not a developer.
He has trouble when it comes to
developing themes,
but Beethoven--Mozart's a
developer,
Beethoven is a developer,
Brahms is a developer,
Mahler is a developer,
and what they develop is,
as I say, a nexus of musical
material.
So this here is the initial
idea >
and we can go back to our
technique >
and then we'd go back down to
the >
, which would lead back to the
tonic.
So we could have one more X
down here but it's the same X as
up there.
All right.
So that's the essential motive
of the first movement.
Let's go on to hear just a
little bit of the second
movement, which is a delightful
scherzo here of the first
symphony of Mahler,
just a scherzo.
>
And now we're going to go on to
a very strange movement,
the third movement,
the slow movement.
Remember in symphonies we
usually have fast,
slow, scherzo,
fast, finale.
Well, in the late eighteenth,
early nineteenth century,
sometimes they'd switch those.
They'd put the scherzo number
two and then the scherzo minuet
number two and then the slow
movement number three,
so here we got the slow
movement as number three.
Let's listen to a bit of it.
See if you can recognize the
melody that Mahler's working
with here.
>
I saw a smile come over Jacob's
face out there.
Jacob.
Student:
"Frère
Jacques."
Prof: "Frère
Jacques"
or in German "Bruder
Martin,"
"Brother Martin,"
"Frère
Jacques,"
but what happened to brother
Martin or "Frère
Jacques"
here?
He got zapped into the--
Student: Minor.
Prof: Minor. Okay.
So this is a kind of gloomy
"Frere Jacques."
It's a weird movement.
In a way, it's taking the
familiar and making it weirdly
unfamiliar.
So that's what happens here in
the slow third movement.
Now we're going to pass on to
the fourth movement 'cause
that's the big-ticket item for
today--this morning--and I think
we have time to cover it.
It's going to start out with
this gigantic kind of opening
fireworks of just pure
orchestral sound and
introduction,
and then a couple of themes
will crop out,
>
and then a little bit later
>.
So we'll have these two themes
here that we'll be working with
and we'll pick up some other
themes a little bit later on.
So let's hear--and we'll all
get ready for a big explosion
here, the beginning of the
finale.
>
So that's the first theme
material there and you have
the--
using the same kind of X-ing
process that we began our course
with,
we can make use of it here to
kind of track or remember these
particular themes.
Myself, I can't always hear
them but if I can visualize them
it helps me.
All right.
So we're going to now go on to
the second theme area.
He's essentially following our
sonata-allegro form here and we
have a long passage.
It goes on for about three
minutes, but it's a
quintessential moment of
romantic music.
It's along the same lines of
the Tchaikovsky that we heard
before.
So let's just start out here
and we'll listen and we'll
comment on what's romantic about
the music that we're hearing.
>
End of transition.
Here comes the theme.
>
What's romantic about that?
Thoughts. Elizabeth.
Student: There's a lot
of slurred notes.
Prof: Okay.
A lot of >.
Yeah, it's a lot of slurred
notes.
Whether that kind of inspires
this to romance I'm not really
sure, but it's not precise;
it's not marching along;
it's not discrete frequencies.
Now what instrument is carrying
the melody here,
is particularly good at that
kind of--what's the German word
in Vienna?
Schlagober,
or something like that for
whipped cream kind of sound,
probably some German--
>
Elizabeth, what instrument is
playing that?
Student: The violins.
Prof: The violins,
and this is because the violins
have this capacity for vibrato
and to slide between pitches.
It gives this this kind of
romantic effect so it's not
marching along in any kind of
precise way here.
All right.
So that's my principal point--a
warm, lush string sound.
Let's go on.
>
I think we really have only
about two minutes left and I do
want to if--
everybody was good enough to
show up on time so I want to let
you leave on time.
Let's go--just to give you a
sense of the sound here,
let's go to the very end of
this.
It's a long movement.
It's about twenty minutes long.
We got about two minutes--two,
three minutes to go,
and you're going to hear this
extreme orchestral contrast here
as it gets bigger and bigger.
Notice that we had a minor
theme here.
The same theme comes back but
he takes out all of the
chromatic minor sound and makes
it all major.
We're going to get lots of
heroic trumpets going on with
that addition to our theme.
Think about this.
This I like to think of as the
last gasp of the traditional
high art classical orchestra.
It never got any better than
this.
It never got any bigger than
this for reasons that we'll
maybe comment on after it.
So let's listen and then one
comment at the end.
>
And one final thought.
Why did it stop here?
Why did--what happened in the
history of art music to change
everything?
Anybody have any idea?
Daniel.
Student:
>
Prof: Exactly.
That's what happened:
electronically produced sound
where you could control the
decibel level and reproduce it.
People started staying home and
playing recordings and they
could manipulate the volume any
way they wanted at that
particular point.
Okay. Thanks for staying on.
Have a great break.
We may--I hope to see you in
sections tonight and Friday and
Monday when you get back.